Ein Feiertag in Indien.
Menschen kommen zu einem Tempel,
um Kühe und Rinder zu spenden.
Manches Tier hat
eine beschwerliche Reise hinter sich.
Esther Geisser
hat schon oft solche Bilder gesehen.
Wieso ist sein Zustand so schlecht?
Wahrscheinlich Mangelernährung
und der ganze Stress der Reise.
Die Trennung von der Mutter,
die Hitze.
Die Schweizerin
ist professionelle Tierschützerin.
Immer wieder reist sie nach Indien,
um Kühe und andere Tiere zu retten.
Es klingt schon seltsam:
eine Schweizerin,
die in Indien Kühe rettet.
Ja, das mag sein.
V.a. weil alle Schweizer denken,
die Kuh sei in Indien heilig.
Ist sie gar nicht so heilig?
Grundsätzlich
wäre sie gut geschützt.
Es gibt einen Cow Prohibition Act,
der viele Vorschriften beinhaltet.
Aber das wird nicht eingehalten.
Und die Gläubigen tun oft so,
als wüssten sie nicht,
was sie anstellen, wenn sie
die Kühe hier einfach abgeben.
* Indische Musik
aus dem Lautsprecher *
Die indische Stadt Visakhapatnam
am bengalischen Meer.
Seit Tagesanbruch ist Esther Geisser
ohne Frühstück unterwegs.
Was ist mit diesem Hund?
Er ist allein,
er hat keine Mutter mehr.
Er war hier auf der Strasse.
Er würde allein nicht überleben.
Die 50-Jährige ist Gründerin
der weltweit tätigen
Tierschutzorganisation NetAP.
Der Hauptsitz
ihrer Partnerorganisation.
Geisser arbeitet
mit lokalen Tierschützern zusammen.
Diese kümmern sich um den Welpen.
Es ist sehr traurig,
dass so kleine Hunde auf der Strasse
sind und niemand reagiert.
Aber jetzt ist er ja gerettet.
Also ist es doch eine positive Sache?
Ja, für diesen Hund. Aber es gibt
viele andere, die wir nicht sehen,
weil wir nicht dort durchfahren.
Pradeep Kumar ist Gründer und Leiter
der Tierschutzorganisation
in Visakhapatnam.
Er hat rund 80 Angestellte.
Ein grosses Anliegen
ist ihnen das Wohl der Kühe.
Ziel ist ein Markt, wo Kühe,
Rinder und Kälber verkauft werden.
Hier ist normalerweise alles voll -
Kühe und auch Schweine.
Nur wenige Tiere sind hier,
wo sonst Hunderte
zum Verkauf angeboten werden.
Oft würden sie dann
illegal geschlachtet.
Hier gibt es kein Wasser.
Wo sind denn all diese Menschen?
Ich weiss nicht, ob der Grund
ein Meeting mit den Behörden ist,
für das wir uns angemeldet haben.
Normalerweise
kommen wir ohne Voranmeldung.
Wollen Sie denn
den Indern quasi vorschreiben,
sie sollen kein Fleisch mehr essen?
Nein, wir wollen
gar nichts vorschreiben.
Wir wollen,
dass das Gesetz durchgesetzt wird.
Und wie lautet das?
Es sollen keine illegalen
Schlachtungen mehr stattfinden,
nur so viele Tiere transportiert
werden, wie erlaubt sind.
Es braucht Schatten und Wasser.
Sie dürfen nicht geschlagen
und gequält werden.
Deshalb sind wir hier.
It's okay. I'll take it.
I'll take it, thank you.
Indien hat
ein sehr scharfes Tierschutzgesetz.
Viele Kühe
dürfen gar nicht getötet werden.
Es müssen strenge Voraussetzungen
erfüllt sein
für das Töten einer Kuh.
Es darf aber sicher
kein Tierleid verursacht werden.
Es gibt strenge
Transportbedingungen.
Es darf nur eine bestimmte Anzahl
von Kühen verladen werden.
Es ist ein dickes Buch
mit Bestimmungen,
die eingehalten werden müssten,
die aber übergangen werden.
Zwei Männer wollen
mit ihren Kälbern das Weite suchen.
Doch sie haben die Rechnung
ohne Tierschützerin
Sridevi Potnurun gemacht.
Hey. Wem gehören diese Tiere?
Wo ist das Futter und das Wasser?
Binde die Tiere wieder an!
Wir nehmen die Tiere jetzt mit.
Ich werde
deine Knochen zerquetschen.
Binde sie fest
oder ich zeige dich an!
Ihr werdet beide
hinter Gitter wandern.
Schämst du dich nicht, illegale
Geschäfte mit Tieren zu machen?
Was hast du mit den Tieren vor?
Wir wollen die Tiere verkaufen.
Zeig mir lieber
deine Identitätskarte.
Zeig sie mir!
Müssen wir immer wieder
hierherkommen, um dich anzuweisen,
den Tieren Futter und Wasser
zu geben? Füttere sie jetzt!
Hier im Bereich mit den Kühen
haben wir extrem starke Frauen,
die ...
Ich habe schon gesehen,
wie die Männer zusammenzuckten,
wenn eine von ihnen kam.
Das ist erstaunlich,
denn die Frauen in Indien
haben nach unserem Verständnis
nicht so viele Rechte.
Vom Gesetz her
sind sie gut geschützt.
Eine Frau könnte sagen:
"Der hat mich unsittlich angefasst",
und er käme in den Knast.
Sie haben schon
Angst vor den Frauen.
Die Polizei ist eingetroffen.
Sie beschlagnahmen die Kälber.
Die Situation bleibt ruhig.
Das ist keine Selbstverständlichkeit,
erzählt Pradeep Kumar.
Ja, es ist gefährlich -
wir sind schon oft attackiert worden
und könnten es jederzeit
wieder werden. Zweifelsohne.
Direkt neben dem Markt
befindet sich das Polizeigebäude.
Eine Sitzung mit den Behörden
ist angesagt.
Der Direktor des Veterinäramtes hat
ein offenes Ohr für die Tierschützer.
Gleichzeitig kennt er aber auch
die Situation der Bauern.
Die meisten der Bauern sind arm.
Für sie ist es nicht einfach,
Tiere zu halten.
Die Lebensbedingungen hier
sind schwierig.
Diese Gegend ist sehr trocken.
Ab Dezember
gibt es kein grünes Gras mehr.
Trotz schwieriger Lebensbedingungen
sollten die Bauern das Gesetz
einhalten, sagen die Tierschützer.
Das gelte auch hier,
wo sich jeder und jede kennt.
Man will natürlich nicht
dem Nachbarn ans Bein pinkeln.
Es ist ein steiniger Weg,
sie zu überzeugen,
dass sie ihre Pflicht wahrnehmen
und die Gesetze einhalten müssen.
Wenn es zu lange dauert, werden wir
einfach den Rechtsweg beschreiten.
Das ist dann auch für eine Behörde
kein Spass.
Innerhalb der letzten drei, vier
Jahre hat sich einiges getan.
Heute habe ich sogar
einen leeren Wassertank gesehen.
Das nächste Mal
wird dann auch Wasser drin sein.
Es wird alles gut.
Du hast es geschafft.
Diese Tiere wurden beschlagnahmt.
Sie kommen jetzt
auf einen Kuh-Lebenshof
und können dort einfach leben.
Sie sind keine Nutztiere mehr.
Wie ist das für Sie?
Das ist ein Glücksmoment,
damit habe ich nicht gerechnet.
Wir können nicht alle retten.
Wir sehen jeden Tag
Hunderte Tiere in Not.
Aber wenn das hier das Resultat ist,
wenn man eines,
das man ins Herz geschlossen hat,
auch gleich retten kann,
dann fühlt sich das gut an.
Dann taucht plötzlich ein Mann auf,
der sich als Besitzer der sechs Tiere
ausgibt. Er fordert sie zurück.
Doch in Wahrheit
handelt es sich um den Metzger.
Sridevi hat ihn erkannt.
Was willst du mir vorspielen?
Gib es zu!
Die Kühe gehören dir gar nicht.
Sonst wanderst du ins Gefängnis.
Der Metzger ist vertrieben.
Jetzt können die Kälber und Rinder in
den Gnadenhof transportiert werden.
Die Tierschützer haben mehrere Ver-
stösse gegen das Gesetz festgestellt.
Es fehlen Papiere. Er hätte sie
so gar nicht verkaufen dürfen.
Abgesehen davon, dass sie
kein Wasser, kein Futter hatten,
dass sie zu jung
für den Markt waren.
Ich muss mir
die Regelverstösse anschauen.
Mir war nicht bewusst,
dass es so viele waren,
dass man sie gleich
beschlagnahmt hat.
Haben Sie kein Mitgefühl
mit dem Bauern?
Er hätte das Gesetz einhalten kön-
nen, dann hätte er keine Probleme.
Kein Mitgefühl?
- Absolut nicht.
Diese Gesetze sind minimal,
und wenn man sie nicht einhält,
dann soll man bestraft werden.
Die Tiere haben so wenig Schutz.
Wenn man nicht einmal
diesen einhält,
muss man bestraft werden.
There are more?
Das ist einer
von insgesamt zwei Gnadenhöfen,
die von der lokalen Tierschutz-
organisation betrieben werden.
Finanziert werden die Farmen
durch Spendengelder.
Esther Geisser überweist rund
100'000 Fr. jährlich nach Indien.
Gelder,
die sie in der Schweiz gesammelt hat.
They are not used to this freedom.
So if you do that,
they run like wild.
Allein auf diesem Hof
leben rund 1'000 Tiere.
Ein kleines Paradies für viele Arten,
die gerettet wurden.
Sie können hier einfach sein,
bis sie irgendwann
eines natürlichen Todes sterben.
Aber das Ziel ist eigentlich,
dass man das System ändert,
dass man keine Tiere retten muss.
Was wäre denn das ideale System?
Dass man
von der Tiernutzung wegkommt.
Bzw. von der Tierausnutzung.
Ich glaube fest daran, denn vor
160 Jahren hatte man noch Sklaven
und glaubte nicht,
dass sich das ändert.
Wir hatten lange
kein Frauenstimmrecht.
Das sind Prozesse,
die Zeit brauchen.
Aber irgendwann
betrachtet man Tiere
nicht mehr als untergeordnete Wesen,
die man ausnutzen kann,
sondern als eigenständiges Leben.
Geisser und ihr Team wollen
den Bauern neue Wege aufzeigen.
Ziel ist es,
ihren Ertrag zu steigern,
ohne Tierleid zu verursachen.
Aus dem Urin der Kühe wird hier z.B.
ein alternatives Heilmittel
hergestellt.
Man hat einen grösseren
wirtschaftlichen Gewinn.
Die Bauern müssen wissen, dass ihr
Profit so grösser ist als mit Milch.
That's good. Super.
Wollen Sie mal probieren -
Kuh-Urin als Medizin?
Ich weiss, dass es in der
ayurvedischen Medizin und anderswo
gang und gäbe ist.
Ich habe es noch nie probiert,
aber offenbar wirkt es.
Ja, es riecht desinfiziert.
Früh am Morgen etwas
von dieser Medizin einzunehmen,
bewahrt dich vor Krankheiten.
Ich sah schon auf der Strasse Leute,
die sich das Mittel
über den Kopf schütteten.
Das mag ich nicht.
Esther Geisser hat Jura studiert.
Zudem ist sie ausgebildete
Verhaltenstherapeutin für Katzen.
Vor zehn Jahren gründete sie
die international tätige
Tierschutzorganisation NetAP.
Seither ist sie
professionelle Tierschützerin.
Sponsoren ermöglichen ihr
einen fixen Lohn.
Es sind zweckgebundene Spenden,
es sind nicht normale Spenden,
die von Normalspendern kommen.
Sondern es sind Personen,
die explizit wollen,
dass ich weiter
im Tierschutz tätig bin.
Schon als Kind
fühlte sie sich zu Tieren hingezogen.
Sie will sie vor ihrem grössten Feind
beschützen: dem Menschen.
Bei Ihnen hat man immer den Eindruck,
dass Ihnen Tiere näher sind
als Menschen.
Ja, das ist natürlich
meine Berufung.
Mein Beruf.
Es füllt
einen grossen Teil meines Lebens.
Es ist ... Oh!
Das Herz schlägt primär für Tiere?
Sie brauchen mich mehr,
sie haben meine Hilfe mehr nötig.
Und sie geben sehr viel.
Sie geben eine bedingungslose Liebe.
Sie nehmen einen so, wie man ist.
Sie akzeptieren einen,
haben keine Vorurteile.
Und sie brauchen unsere Hilfe.
Denn wir quälen,
missbrauchen und nutzen sie aus.
Ja, sie haben uns nötiger denn je.
Tausende Strassenhunde
wurden schon eingefangen,
um sie zu kastrieren
und gegen Tollwut zu impfen.
Davon würden auch die Menschen
in Visakhapatnam profitieren,
sagt die Schweizerin.
Seit Beginn der Impfaktion
vor acht Jahren
sei kein Mensch mehr an
der gefährlichen Infektion erkrankt.
Aus welchem Grund
sind Sie hier so aufmerksam dabei?
Wir kastrieren pro Jahr
rund 5'000 Hunde,
aber fast keine Katzen,
weil das niemand kann.
Das Wissen über Katzen war bei null.
Jetzt wurden die Tierärzte trainiert
und sie können es.
Das war der Startschuss
zu einem Katzen-Kastrationsprogramm,
das wir jetzt führen wollen.
Über 100'000 Katzen wurden schon
in der Schweiz unter Geissers
Federführung kastriert und geimpft.
Machen sie es gut?
Ja, bis jetzt
machen sie es wirklich gut.
Und ich bin auch beeindruckt,
wie sie
die Hygienevorschriften einhalten.
Besser als einige Tierärzte
in der Schweiz.
Wirklich?
- Ja.
* Ruhige indische Musik *
Wo immer sie ist,
überall entdeckt sie Tierleid.
Das macht mich wütend.
Es ist so unnötig,
es ist reine Quälerei.
Es gäbe so einfache Dinge, die
ihnen das Leben erleichtern würden.
Z.B. Wasser geben.
Ist das hier Ihre Welt?
Ja, Gemüse ist mir lieber.
Damit kann man nicht viel
falsch machen. Es ist auch gesünder.
Sie essen also kein Fleisch?
- Nein.
Ich habe mit fünf Jahren aufgehört,
als ich merkte,
dass es nicht am Baum wächst.
Ist das der Grund?
Ja, ich realisierte,
dass etwas sterben muss,
damit ich es essen kann.
Das fand ich sehr, sehr seltsam.
Das wollte mir nicht einleuchten.
Haben Sie auch schon
die Erfahrung gemacht,
dass man sie deswegen
für schwierig hält?
Das würde man mir
wohl nicht direkt sagen,
aber einige halten mich für extrem.
Ich würde eher sagen,
ich bin konsequent,
und das macht den Menschen
manchmal Angst.
Man bekommt
einen Spiegel vorgehalten
und beginnt vielleicht,
nachzudenken.
Sie machen anderen
ein schlechtes Gewissen?
Jeder, der versucht,
etwas zu verändern,
und der auf dem Weg ist,
weniger Leid zu verursachen,
macht anderen, die nicht bereit
sind, diesen Weg zu beschreiten,
ein schlechtes Gewissen.
Das liegt in der Natur der Sache.
Bist du eine Süsse!
Du bist ganz süss.
Wollten Sie nie eigene Kinder haben?
Nein, das hätte keinen Platz
in meinem Leben.
Ich bin
mit dem Tierschutz ausgefüllt.
Ich hätte den Tierschutz
zurückstellen müssen,
das wollte ich nicht.
Auch ihr Lebenspartner in der Schweiz
denkt so wie sie
und unterstützt sie im Tierschutz.
* Helle Glocke *
Hochbetrieb im Hindutempel
Simhachalam der Stadt Visakhapatnam.
Wir haben im Moment heilige Monate.
Die Gläubigen bringen ihre Kälber
in den Tempel, um sie zu spenden.
Das ist sehr heuchlerisch, denn
sie wollen die Kälber loswerden.
In Indien ist es verboten,
Jungtiere zu schlachten.
Also ist es einfacher,
sie einem Tempel zu spenden,
in der Annahme,
dass es ihnen gut gehe.
Im Tempel sind jedoch
nur die indischen Kühe willkommen.
Alle anderen Tiere
werden oft illegal geschlachtet.
Das wissen viele Gläubige nicht.
Deshalb werden sie
von den Tierschützern
am Eingang zum Heiligtum abgefangen.
Bring dein Kalb da rüber!
Spende dem Tempel lieber Geld
als ein Tier.
Geh!
Das Vieh kommt zu Bauern, die
respektvoll mit den Tieren umgehen.
Doch einige Rinder
sind zu schwach für den Transport.
Ein ortsansässiger Tierarzt
ist eingetroffen.
Esther Geisser hat veranlasst,
ihn zu rufen.
Er hat Mühe, die Blutbahn zu finden,
um die Infusion zu legen.
Die Schweizerin ärgert sich.
Es dauert schon lange, bis er kam.
Er telefonierte lange rum,
obwohl es ein Notfall war.
Er will sich wohl auf keinen Fall
die Finger schmutzig machen.
Wieso denken Sie das?
Er ist ja Tierarzt.
Tierarzt bedeutet nicht,
dass jemand auch tierlieb ist.
Tierarzt kann auch einfach
ein Einkommen sein.
Die Hilfe kommt zu spät.
Das Rind stirbt.
An diesem frühen Morgen
geht es um die Rettung
einer vom Aussterben bedrohten Art.
Die Bastardschildkröte wurde durch
Umwelt und Fischerei stark dezimiert.
Das ist so toll.
Ich bin so glücklich
über dieses Projekt.
Das ist so genial.
Nur gerade eine von 1'000 gezüchteten
Schildkröten wird überleben.
Esther Geisser weiss,
dass ein gerettetes Tier
die Welt kaum verändert.
Aber für das eine Tier
verändert sich die ganze Welt.
Und dafür lebt sie.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Alexandra Duttweiler - 2019